hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 19 of my 1hour flipping challenge
today we're going to be doing
Kalisto uh drops for 1 hour uh some of
the major drops are going to be a
tyrannical ring uh dragon
pickaxe and uh I guess Dragon long sword
anyway um those are the unique drops
everything else has a good amount of
runes and seeds and uh other consumable
drops are good to flip and and yeah
we're just going to start with 40 mil
and let's get started okay everybody we
are about to get started uh we have 40
mil today uh cuz the tyrannical ring is
quite expensive uh so we're going to do
1 hour of flipping Kalisto drops only
and let's
go okay so we're going to start by
popping in a tyrannical
ring now this is a very expensive item I
have it open here
somewhere um yeah it looks like 200k
margin
hopefully um let's look at the
day and let's just pop it in there for
63 20 maybe I don't
know and yeah we'll just okay there we
go we got one in and we'll see how that
goes um moving on did not even look at
the drop table I just hit record and
let's see how this goes oh Dragon
pickaxe
again
yeah
uh yeah I know uh crushed nests I
actually did want to
try crushed
nests um we're going to buy them for
3900 and uh sell them for
3700 um yeah definitely do some of
those and I don't really know how many
we could expect to get we'll just try a
thousand not sure how reasonable that is
yeah a hogy log I have a ton traded I
did not not sure what I was expecting
there 517 and
uh 10,000 I think that's a limit
probably um 11,000 but whatever close
enough uh it's not awful um 40
257 and uh 69 9 it's only going to cost
us 2 mil for that uh Snap Dragons have
an 800 GP margin which is not bad 29 2
three and do
199 uh yeah 800 GP on RAR seeds so we'll
go ahead and do some of these as
well uh another 199 someone asked me
about that it's just because um if you
hit the limit you can't check later to
see if the price has changed uh so I
just kind of like doing that Rune
pickaxe never worked too well for us
cannonballs are good might leave that
just for a little bit
later um what is
what uh 4 GP on blood runes is pretty
decent and I might as well just toss
death runes in there as well unless
there's a little more expensive item we
could do 67
to4 and uh we'll just try a th000 and
see how it goes okay guys we bought all
the blood runes um this is what I was
talking about we bought
9,995 um so we'll just have to take our
word for it that the uh sell price is
still
$279 um I mean 40K hopefully we can sell
those quickly okay so that was not an
issue at all they sold in like 5 minutes
uh so that's our first completed flip of
to the episode 50k 40K sorry uh Rune
long swords actually or Rune two Ander
sorry all came through
so we'll just double check that again
Rune two
hander ah see another issue well
um oh God I think it was like
4800 or something we're selling
for
[Music]
4790 okay we got death runes to do
still
um bom for
264 and and sold them for 260 that's
another 40K pretty easily right there
okay we sold all the Rune swords or two
handers uh so that's nice we have about
four mil probably going to do some
cannonballs uh 206
into 202 another nice amount from
cannonballs pretty sure cannon balls
have a 7K limit on
them and uh pretty easy flip there okay
we sold all the mogy logs already
crazily quick um that's a nice 100K so
we definitely want to try to buy more
here we have another 6K that we can do
uh Snap Dragon seeds though have come
through um so we probably made the same
mistake again we can't actually check it
again
700 U 5910 and we on for 5810 so that's
another 100K in Snap Dragon seeds Okay
uh we bought all the cannonballs and
we're going to plop them in for
206 um
that's
28k uh it's not awful okay we bought all
the Death runes for uh 260 I
believe and we're going to sell them for
not a large profit there let's just pop
him for like 263 or something what we
actually had it before as cuz it does
change a
lot and pop them for 263 and just hope
uh the price will change on us okay
super compost has have a pretty
reasonable margin on them uh they don't
I wouldn't expect to get too many of
these uh but we'll go for
2,000 and well there you go look the
death runes all sold so we ended up 30k
for that instead uh it's much nicer okay
uh we're going to do some magic logs
again H not a huge margin but uh it's
there that is uh 7
GP uh so we'll get 7K
14k 28k
okay reduce the cannonballs down to uh
204 and we did sell them all off uh so
not a huge profit there but not too bad
um I think we'll probably plop in these
crushed nests uh cuz we have gotten a
fair amount of them so
far and it's a pretty decent margin 38
to5 is what we'll sell them
for hopefully oh yeah I forgot we have
the soul Rune available as well oh wow
the soul Rune is actually much cheaper
than I
remember 142 into 136 pretty
decent um I really don't know how many
uh solar runes are traded an hour it's
not an item I do a whole lot uh but I
mean it's used a whole lot so you'd
think uh by that logic you would
uh be able to flip it in an hour but uh
we'll
see
um yeah to million yeah shouldn't be an
issue at all okay there we go we
actually sold all the crushed nests
pretty much all at once which is kind of
exciting I sold him for
2955 and we bought him
for uh 2700 So that was actually 250k in
Profit just off the crush
Nest
2550 and do another
120 and then we'll pop in the rest of
the seeds for a pretty decent profit 26
330 and 088 we're popping in the magic
logs for uh so
86 88 and we're going to buy them all
for
[Music]
8588 yeah yeah 100K not bad uh Magic
seeds actually all came through at once
um so nice we got oh that's actually a
really good profit ah I
should I keep buying more of those we
bought them for 2654 and sold for 28
three no wait a sec wait a sec that's an
extra seed that's a pretty big
difference there but we still probably
get a 100K or so okay we bought all
these Soul runes um sure it was like 142
or something uh which is a nice margin
for
runes I mean palm tree seeds I just
checked have a very good margin on them
I wish i' had done them
earlier um but now we'll go for 20 as
well and just I mean we still have 22
minutes left that's a reasonable amount
of time to do a couple more flips oh
yeah I forgot about mahogany logs that's
something we're going to do just the
margin changed a lot but maybe it's good
again
539 and 518 yeah that's good we got like
another 6,000 of these I'm pretty sure I
can do that's a good use of our money we
still got 14 mil left 40 mil might have
been a little overkill for this boss
considering um the tyrannical ring is
pretty much a nonf factor I unfortunate
uh because there's not a whole lot
differentiating the bosses besides like
their main drops like tyrannical ring or
the dragon pickaxe and normally I do try
to look at the drops a bit oh my God
just smashed my router um before I do
them but today I just I don't know it
was getting late just kind of wanted to
do a video before I went to bed so I
just picked something uh just happens
that the two main drops are worthless uh
but that's okay um the other option for
this episode was one hour flipping fruit
which was actually my original idea for
this series I was going to do just silly
little challenges instead of making them
more serious uh but I decided to take a
more practical approach to it uh but I
was kind of looking at doing something
kind of funny or troll like when I
flipping fruit or when I flipping
vegetables or when I
flipping uh boot strap I don't know
something weird like that so if you guys
were interested in that leave a comment
otherwise that's totally understandable
okay we sold off all the magic logs
that's nice uh got a solid profit from
that okay so we have actually bought
most of the mahogany log so at this
point I think we're just going to call
it that and just try to dump
these
[Music]
for
for 539 GP each we sold all the rear
seeds we don't seem to be buying any
more uh but we only have like 14 minutes
left anyway
um so yeah we'll just wait it out okay
like a second later all my RAR seeds
bought uh which is exciting because
that's just more money in the bag
hopefully we can still get a why am I
lagging I upgraded my hey I upgraded my
router or my wireless adapter to 5 GHz
the other day okay there we go the soul
runes have finally sold I think we
got I just realized never mind um that
that is a 6 to8 GP margin on the soul
runes so pretty decent okay uh RAR seeds
are back up to 26 uh 200
roughly uh so hopefully we can sell
these at this price point uh
26 to oh my God I think the server is
actually lagging s and we sold the palm
tree seeds as well uh it's not too bad
and we're in the last of a minute so
hopefully uh we end strong and there we
go the RAR seeds have totally sold for
26 6 200 I don't know if we can see how
much we made off these uh bomb for 3 mil
and 6K and
sold okay never mind ignore that uh
let's look at the palm tree seeds uh got
11k in profit there uh pretty nice and
that's all we can see okay guys and
that's going to be it we're down to have
4 minutes left I actually remember the
last time I ended one of these early um
but we sold off all the mahogany logs
there's literally no no point for us to
keep going um what we got more than 1
mil that's crazy actually um but anyway
yeah we'll just stop the timer here and
uh yeah that was 1 hours of flipping uh
what boss were we doing isn't
Kalisto with almost zero Kalisto drops
uh and by almost I mean entirely no
clisto drops um but that being said
let's see how much we actually made in 1
hour uh so we made about 1 mil 1 mil in
43k which is quite a bit more than I
thought um again the I guess we did get
we got like 250k on at least two flips
so like seeds uh the runes were pretty
consistent we got a lot on Magic logs
yeah all added up actually kind of makes
sense we got one more uh so yeah hope
you guys enjoyed if you want to see more
episodes like this please please uh hit
that subscribe button to stay subscribed
and I will see you guys next
[Music]
time